eventually I'll get into spoilers but I
wanted to try to squeeze into
non-spoiler questions to start here is
Reading in the notes that you said
sometimes uh you wanted to lean into the
tropes or cliches of the mythology and
then sometimes you didn't so can you
give me an example of one specific Trope
that you wanted to embrace but then one
that you felt was necessary to subvert
in this movie
um things like well opening with a
babysitter horror sequence you know you
take these iconic movies like when a
stranger calls and and you find
influence and inspiration in movies like
that and then so you've established
something that people feel is a little
familiar and then you show them a Twist
at the end of our cold open that they
didn't see coming it's very effective
twist right there it's so hard not to
ask you spoiler questions right now but
let's get into this one non-spoilery to
start and then maybe we can elaborate
after but I am very curious how much did
the trajectory of the story of this
whole trilogy change from you know
original Inception day one of knowing
you were making a Trilogy to what we
wound up getting in ends ultimately
um I don't know how I don't know that it
changed in any radical form there were
things that we evolved
when we were writing kills and Lori was
bedridden because she would because
she's been stabbed in the belly a few
times I knew we needed to make a Time
jump or we decided after thinking about
it there was a period of time where it
was going to be all one linear
continuous type of movie but then she's
you know then how are you going to get
this climactic battle out of her so then
we made decisions to evolve it and say
okay there's a time job between kills
and ends and and it became a great
opportunity and discovery of the fact
that we can have and we can meet an
optimistic Lorry Strode that has gone to
therapy perhaps and she's decorating for
Halloween she's inviting this this
holiday she's making pumpkin pies you
know so we can see a lawyer that's in
many ways the opposite of the Lorry that
we met in 2018 and and to me that just
becomes a discovery you get from
workshopping the script with my beloved
co-writers and talking to the actors
um
turning a camera on things that work and
work less and and then trying to sculpt
something you feel like is the most
satisfying obviously kills is just uh
kind of a chaotic art film middle
chapter for me
um it's just a uh a Michael Myers Opera
and then ends I just wanted to build to
make sure I felt emotional I felt
atmosphere
um I felt romance like there's I wanted
it to be a love song to the fans uh and
and I don't think anyone's Gonna See It
Coming they certainly wouldn't expect us
to take some of the make some of the
choices we've made can confirm I did not
I didn't see a lot of this coming all
right I'm just gonna put up the spoiler
warning for our viewers if you have not
seen Halloween ends this is where you
push pause you go see the movie then you
come back to this exact link and push
plane it starts right here so you're all
set all right I kind of want to open up
that question to spoilers now as well is
there any particular thing that happens
in ends that you know caught you by
surprise where the plan was to go you
know path a but all of a sudden you
realize something and then had a pivot
to be I don't know that we ever have to
but one of the things we did on the on
ends we had four writers Danny McBride
Paul Logan Chris Bernier and myself and
so sometimes we'd get to a point and it
would be Choose Your Own Adventure and
so we'd get to a point and say okay
Corey is at the bottom of the staircase
Lori is upstairs you go this way I'll go
that way and then everybody explore an
Avenue and so we have infinite drafts of
these of these sequences you know not
just a page one to page 90. I try to
keep scripts about 90 Pages like uh it's
not just a full script but it's like
here we are now I know we feel good here
you go here you go you know and it's fun
to do those Explorations and then get
together and we read everybody's and we
Workshop what works what doesn't and
typically what wins is the one that I'm
surprised by The Audacity Of doing this
the the unexpected version here the
twist there
um that just makes it more for an
audience it just makes it more fun I
think can you give me an example of that
of you know a set of pages you read
where you're like whoa like I didn't
think we were gonna do it but that's a
great idea now we got to pursue it
um
Lori puts a gun in her mouth
one end
out like a light another end
maybe not yeah okay that's a big one
there here's here's another really big
question with a movie like this you made
a Halloween movie and you hid Michael
for a real real long time so what was it
like figuring out you know how long you
could actually pull that off for and
then what was the best way to like bring
him back into the fold and earn the way
you bring him back it it's still a
controversy today I just watched the
movie outside of a technical format
meaning in a sound mix or a color
correction for the first time two days
ago like we really just finished this
movie
um so two days ago and it's still
I I'm watching it and and
I'm like this we're asking a lot but
then when we were in the editing room
and we would do differently it felt
wrong and so if you don't have an
intuition if you don't have a vision you
shouldn't be making this movie and I
think uh there's there's obvious
challenges and things that you would
um would bring to discussion with
editors with producers and say this is
what this is what feels right and at a
point we all just looked at each other
and said and said we're taking a big
risk here but it does feel right and we
know what we're getting into let's go
for it okay so that's part one of a big
risk with a Halloween movie a part two
of that is
you kill Michael Myers so what was it
really
I mean so I mean I'm very hung up he's
done the line of uh the idea of you know
the the shape of evil changing that's
that's an idea that's very exciting to
me but you know at least in this
specific movie you're leaving us we've
got that that's a fun one oh yeah I do I
dig that quite a bit but what was it
like doing that and you know having some
confidence that die hard Halloween fans
out there are going to appreciate that
not necessarily go like like Howie dare
you make it make it feel at least that
definitive when we're filming that
definitive moment there are 200 people
standing around a mechanism watching
that and it's you could hear a pin drop
uh it's a it's this loud ass grinding
mechanism and there's not one person
that's making any noise at all it's just
total silence and that's kind of when
we're all hypnotized by what's happening
and I felt like because most of the
production of this movie is in all these
movies are just Explorations we're
trying things we're seeing if this looks
like do we want to show this let's Film
It Anyway let's have it in the editing
room let's play with it and so the whole
movie is those types of playful
considerations and that scene in
particular we're just mesmerized and
then when we looked at it and it worked
and it's beautiful and strange and quiet
and
but you know again you got you got to
stick with some direction that you're
going and that one just felt peaceful in
a way my brain is conditioned to think
that the killer can come back this is
probably one of the most definitive
feeling endings to uh like a slasher
icon story to me I was very very Blown
Away by how you really just went for it
like a hundred percent and Beyond
um with that in mind I kind of wanted to
Loop in Exorcist what what is something
about the way you're bringing back that
franchise that stays consistent with
having brought back Halloween but then
also what is something that that
particular story demands that's unique
to how you brought back Halloween it's
inevitable that since I'm making these
franchise returns kind of back to back
it's inevitable people will compare them
but they're nothing alike that there's
Halloween is a is a a
is a horror film it's a slasher movie
it's a it's midnight madness good time
at the movies eat some popcorn Exorcist
is a very researched
drama uh about [ __ ] up things and and
so uh spirituality religion Mental
Health
um family and and it's
um
there's you can overlap those two in
these very different subgenres of horror
but the approach technically creatively
is very different the the similarity is
we're taking Chris McNeil The Ellen
burstin
um created that character in 1970 and
we're taking a 50-year
uh so 50 years later we're we're
checking in on her again and seeing
where she's a part of this Ensemble the
the the the the leads of the film or
Leslie Odom Jr and and Dowd
and and and
you know a great Ensemble of actors that
we've I can't say them out loud because
I don't think they've been announced yet
but uh and then and then Ellen is a part
of that Journey returning to that role
and it's so it's just for me I love
having an anchor of perspective and so I
feel like I'm dealing with this isn't
historical subject matter but I'm
dealing with
historic cinematic characters and I've
got the iconic actress that played this
part 50 years ago and she's there to ask
questions she's there to evaluate give
me notes on the script and she's become
like my spiritual Guru that I go to
which he's traveled the world and the
just the way that the film affected her
life we found ways that the story that
we're creating
affected uh Chris McNeil in certain ways
so he's gonna ask a broader question
about knowing when to bring something
back and when a franchise should end but
someone recently uh told me this quote
from Joe Wright about uh like you
shouldn't take on a new script or a new
opportunity unless you think you have a
secret about that story so what is your
secret about the Exorcist that's
uniquely you have one year before you
get to learn my secret
I'll take it I'll take it I know I Gotta
Wait sometimes
um speaking of the future or the
potential future of this franchise it
was reading a quote that I think you
would gave like a year ago where you
were explaining how like you had your
fun and now it's time to say good night
to the franchise and move on but you're
basically leaving this mythology open to
a new Creator to tap in and explore it
more what would you want to see in a new
writer director or whoever what
qualities do you think they need to have
to continue exploring the ideas that you
leave us with and ends
we'll see if I had that idea then I'd
just keep doing them because they're so
much fun to make
I just again I think that like we've
tried to be very honorable and authentic
so the next thing should be Kabuki you
know this the next story could be a a
Bollywood musical of it you know I I
think I I'd watch someone should take a
radically different approach than I did
and and prove me wrong and give me
something to argue about and I want to
get into that fan spot again where I'm
just sitting in the audit being like Boo
yay I love it I hate it you know I want
to get back in that form because that's
that's where the real adrenaline is as
much as I'm eager for you to keep making
movies now you have this platform and
you can find another up-and-coming
filmmaker who can absolutely crush it I
like it too that kind of support and and
Malacca Cod who uh who owns the property
um with trancus like I like I just I
know that he's thinking already I know I
mean he's he's a wonderful mind and been
a great collaborator on this and I just
know that he's like what's next and and
I think it's a a really important
decision he's got to make squeeze in one
last question before they kick me out of
here and I I suppose it's like more
theorizing and I don't know if you're
going to want to explain this away but
it's specifically about Corey do you
think that he was he was basically
doomed from the very beginning had that
incident at the beginning of the movie
not happen do you think he would have
found a better path in life or would he
have ended up where we see him end up
anyway my argument and that the film
kind of poses that same question and I
like I like that the film doesn't
doesn't answer doesn't answer it but my
answer is if it hadn't been in
Haddonfield at that time of communal
collapse I think there would have been
people to turn to he didn't have a
mother he could turn to in that problem
uh I think he would have had people he
could turn to that could have
yeah
manifested positivity as opposed to evil
because this is like one of my biggest
burning Bernie questions now
was there ever a version of this Trilogy
Where Karen made it to ends no she was
always toast don't tell Judy so so much
for her like I wanted her to come back
as a ghost I don't care do any like
cliche break any rule you want I just
wanted her back I know I was texting
with her the other day being like I
gotta show you this movie so you can
punch me in the face